Right?
So coming to the fights this weekend,
I was invited.
I was like,
hopefully we get along and have a fucking dope.
We got along.
It was fine.
I have massive respect.
You know,
Brian's a crazy motherfucker.
I tell a story,
you know,
that whole school down there,
it was,
I wanted to tell the story about mine because he
fucking,
he's hilarious.
He's,
I used to take,
uh,
Tony Rts is one of the senior students or master choice.
Another guy won't,
we'll call him chuck,
but he's with the government now.
He's a fucking bad motherfucker.
So they always used to go around and,
and,
and wanna fight balances and all this shit.
That was what they did.
They would fucking fight the biggest,
scariest looking motherfuckers and just destroyed him.
So blue worked.
I said his name,
sorry.
But my friend worked with a cro mags and stuff.
We took them out security,
uh,
with us in case we have problems or whatever.
So it was like everything always went smooth.
So one time I used to work at all the underground hip hop clubs in New York.
So my friend was doing a party and it was all fucking deep Brooklyn heads,
fucking like homeboys and shit like the real deal.
This hip hop club and I take Brian,
another dude from the school and Tony and we go over there and Brian is in the
middle of the fucking dance floor doing the Funky fucking white boy nerd dance
and all these fuck.
And the floor just opens up in these fucking black fuck and hip hop crazy
fucking homeboys are like,
Yo,
look at this mother fucking white boy.
Like it's bugging and he don't give a fuck.
He's ill.
Seriously,
like a fucking piss it have to roll with.
So then I might go,
ah,
I got to go.
But listen man,
I know what y'all motherfuckers do.
Don't start.
No Shit,
please.
It's my friend's club.
So I get home,
go to sleep,
wake up the next day I get a fucking phone call,
Yo.
Like he didn't know that they were with me.
He's like,
Yo,
there was these three fucking karate experts in the club last night and they
beat up all my fucking bouncers.
Dude.
It was fucking crazy.
Like,
and,
uh,
one bounce walked up and started some shit with,
Tony was trying to talk to a girl,
whatever.
And,
and then like,
you know,
this guys all on the juice rips off his shirt like,
fuck a Tony throws a kick,
fucking dislocates the guy's fucking knee cap.
And then,
uh,
the melee just ensued any,
it,
it was just constant.
These fucking huge bouncers,
common Adam and Brian sack.
I fucking,
Brian could fight.
Brian is a,
uh,
you know,
he's,
he's a comedian,
but he could throw it down.
And then he,
Brian just told me this because I didn't hear the other party.
He goes,
yeah,
then all of a sudden I'm fucking whack and these dudes and us,
we're fighting these guys.
And then this fucking gigantic motherfucker.
Like I was just like a little fucking baby in his arms,
lifts me up and carries me out the fucking door and throws me across this car.
And I look and I turned around and I'm ready to go.
And then Brian says,
and I look in,
it's this fucking crazy white dude with a fucking scar from one end of his face
down his throat and he points at behind it goes,
don't even think about it.
And like Brian was like,
Yo,
well my friend called me up the next day,
he's like these motherfuckers and I called him up and I'm Mike Bryant.
The fuck did you do man,
I told you guys to fucking keep chill.
He's like,
Yo,
these bounces were assholes and you know it was,
he's,
he's a,
he's a character.
Like I said,
I was at his first comedy show ever.
He lived a wildlife in his young days.
I met him after all that stuff.
I met him when he was more calm.
I met him in the 90s yeah.
Yeah.
They were in big time.
Master Choi was all about fucking getting out there and fucking contact.
There was a lot of martial arts coaches,
instructors that wanted you to get in street fights.
Yeah.
Cause you would practice cause it looks,
treat fights would show you how things would work in the real world.
That the more you did it,
the more you understood urgency,
closing the distance,
you know,
delivering the first strike,
all that kind of shit.
Like people were hesitant.
Cause in sparring you always hold back.
So like,
you know,
I Wando background.